ce général du bord de mer alors déjà
qu'est ce que ça fait de commencer un
mandat sous ses auspices crise sanitaire
et bien vraiment ça nous oblige à pas
encore fait encore plus attention
ça nous oblige à travailler dans les
conditions inédites ça nous oblige à
être beaucoup plus responsable pour nous
mêmes et pour une population
et puis ça nous fait nous projeter aussi
parce que nous aurons certainement
quelques difficultés financières qui
peuvent intervenir sur la réalisation de
certaines sommes d'investissement que
nous aurons alors précisément quel est
le premier gros investissements que vous
souhaiteriez enclenché et qui pourrait
être compromis pendant quelques semaines
ou quelques mois du fait de la crise
financière différence alors nous sommes
terres agricoles au mans le vert et nous
avons pris le pari de désenclaver toutes
les terres agricoles scène de la commune
pour permettre aux agriculteurs
justement de produire sainement et de
nourrir le pays sainement donc nous
avons deux reprocher parce que nous
sommes nous avons une topographie un
petit peu bousculé mouvementée et nous
avons de gros désenclavement à faire
pour permettre aux agriculteurs le
travail dans de bonnes conditions de
produits dans de bonnes conditions et de
nourrir sainement puisque nous avons la
chance de ne pas avoir les terres
chlordécone et dans ce pays à la
dernière question sur l'installation de
conseillers de ce conseil municipal ce
samedi avec une ambiance très paisible
consensuelle
est-ce que c'est l'habitude de monomères
ou est-ce que c'est du oui constance
accule normale vers nous sommes une
grande famille on se connaît tous